tenemos otros vídeos que ven con cierta
profundidad el ciclo de calvin en este
vídeo nos referiremos a él como el ciclo
de calvin normal y el enfoque de este
vídeo es realmente una peculiaridad que
nos desvía del ciclo de calvin normal y
es una peculiaridad de vida a esta
enzima justo aquí cuyo nombre abreviado
es rubisco así que para conocer un poco
más acerca de esa peculiaridad primero
vamos a hacer un resumen muy rápido de
un ciclo de calvin normal podemos
empezar en cualquier punto pero voy a
empezar en el punto en que comúnmente se
inicia vamos a empezar con esta molécula
de 5 carbonos y solo estamos
visualizando los carbonos aquí por
simplicidad así que cada uno de estos
círculos grises representa un carbono
hay otros átomos que forman parte de
esta molécula pero no los hemos dibujado
y eso es debido a que la contabilización
de los carbonos es lo que es interesante
no sólo en el ciclo de calvin
no también en esta variación o
desviación que vamos a ver a la cual
vamos a llamar foto respiración por aquí
lo he dibujado de manera que tenemos
seis moléculas y llamamos a esto tribu
los a 15 bis fosfato y dado que es un
nombre muy grande la notación abreviada
es rv p a veces la gente le llama rubén
p y cada uno de estos seis r vps pueden
reaccionar con un dióxido de carbono
tengo seis r vps así que van a
reaccionar con seis dióxido de carbono y
así una manera de pensar en ello es que
está fijando el carbono contenido en el
dióxido de carbono está tomando este
carbono que es parte de este dióxido de
carbono gaseoso y lo fija como parte de
una molécula orgánica ahora podrías
estar pensando en que va a crear seis
moléculas de 6 carbonos pero estás
inmediatamente se convertirán en 12
moléculas de 3 carbonos y observa que y
es importante hacer esto
puedes pausar el vídeo si es necesario
vamos a asegurarnos de contabilizar
todos los átomos de carbono por aquí
cuántos átomos de carbono tenemos
tenemos 6 por 5 así que tenemos 30
carbonos y por acá tenemos 6 por un
átomo de carbono así que tenemos 6
carbonos así que aquí deberíamos tener
36 carbonos y así es tenemos dos
moléculas de 3 carbonos estas moléculas
de 3 carbonos cuando veamos esto con más
detalle en el vídeo del ciclo de calvin
veremos que se llaman 3 fósforo klee
cerato pero no nos vamos a centrar en
esto por ahora el enfoque de este vídeo
es la enzima que hace la fijación del
carbono junto con la rv y esa enzima el
personaje con la peculiaridad de la que
vamos a hablar su nombre es rigurosa 15
vy fosfato carboxilasa oxigena za
es un nombre muy extenso aún más extenso
que el de la rv p por lo que se le
conoce también por su nombre abreviado
rubisco y se puede saber mucho acerca de
lo que hace rubisco si analizamos un
poco su nombre e incluso se puede saber
un poco acerca de su peculiaridad de la
que estamos a punto de hablar así que la
molécula utiliza una rigurosa 15 bis
fosfato por acá y luego vemos
carboxilasa guión oxigenas a la
carboxilasa es lo que nos dice que
pueden lidiar con el dióxido de carbono
por aquí que el dióxido de carbono puede
ser uno de los sustratos en una reacción
con larri bulos a 15 bis fosfato y eso
es exactamente lo que está haciendo en
esta reacción en un ciclo de calvin
normal está actuando como una
carboxilasa está fijando ese carbono
está tomando estas moléculas de carbono
y las está fijando como moléculas
orgánicas algunas de las cuales pueden
ser utilizadas para crear glucosa
y eso es lo que ocurre en un ciclo de
calvin típico utilizamos algunos enea de
ph es utilizamos algunos a tps y
continuamos avanzando en el ciclo y
creamos algunos g3 pets que también son
moléculas de 3 carbonos que 3 p es la
abreviatura de glitter aldehído 3
fosfato para aquellos de ustedes que
estén interesados en saber y luego si
utilizamos el conteo de estos 12 10
vuelvan a pasar por el ciclo de calvin
para regenerar nuestra rigurosa 15 bis
fosfato y dos de ellos se salen del
ciclo de calvin y luego se pueden
utilizar para producir una molécula de
glucosa de 6 carbonos y eso es lo que
sucede cuando todo está funcionando bien
ese es el propósito del ciclo de calvin
poder tener una reserva de energía en
forma de glucosa ahora posiblemente ya
hayas podido vislumbrar a partir del
nombre de rubisco
a veces puede actuar como una oxigena sa
así que en lugar de fijar el carbono
puede a veces fijar el oxígeno y esa es
la peculiaridad de la que les quería
hablar con respecto a la enzima rubisco
así que en la foto respiración en lugar
de fijar el carbono fija el oxígeno
junto con la rigurosa 15 mis fosfatos y
podrías decir por qué lo hace y la
respuesta es bueno eso es una muy buena
pregunta algunas personas piensan que es
sólo una de las ineficiencias de un
proceso biológico que no debería hacerlo
es en cierto modo perjudicial para la
planta podría ser un efecto secundario o
una función de heredada o un efecto
secundario de la evolución antigua
cuando había muy poco oxígeno en la
atmósfera por lo que esto no parecía ser
algo tan malo o algo ineficiente pero es
algo que ocurre a veces y en particular
las veces en que es más probable que
ocurra la foto respiración con plantas
típicas a menudo referidas como plantas
3 y se les llama así debido a que el
primer producto cuando se fija el
carbono es una molécula de 3 carbonos
pero esto ocurre con plantas típicas en
climas más calientes de lo usual así que
permítanme escribir esto
climas
muy
calientes
y porque un clima muy caliente pues bien
en condiciones de calor en primer lugar
rubisco tiene más afinidad por el
oxígeno
afinidad
d
robisco
por él
oxígeno
aumenta
así en condiciones normales tiende a
tener más afinidad por el dióxido de
carbono pero en condiciones de calor
estas proteínas pueden transformarse un
poco por lo que tiene más afinidad por
el oxígeno molecular y también en
condiciones de calor las plantas están
preocupadas por conservar agua y así van
a cerrar sus esto más cierran
sos
esto más
para preservar el agua
pero cuando los estomas están cerrados
el co2 no puede entrar
co2
no
puede
entrar y el o2 no puede salir el o2
no puede
salir
por lo que la proporción de oxígeno con
respecto al dióxido de carbono aumenta
así que la
proporción
d
todos
respecto
co2
aumenta así que en climas muy calientes
la rubisco prefieren trabajar con el
oxígeno aunque por lo general quiere
trabajar con el dióxido de carbono y
también debido a que los estomas están
cerrados y los gases no pueden penetrar
esta relación va a aumentar y así las
cosas son más propensas a reaccionar con
el oxígeno especialmente el a rubisco
tiene más probabilidades de chocar con
el oxígeno de la manera correcta que con
el dióxido de carbono pero vamos a
pensar un poco acerca de por qué esto es
ineficiente en este caso se está fijando
el oxígeno por lo que no está ganando
esos carbonos a diferencia de lo que
acabamos de ver en el ciclo de calvin
normal aquí podemos contar los carbonos
y te invito a que pausa este vídeo y
hagas un conteo de los átomos de carbono
pero en este caso ya no podemos producir
las 12 moléculas de 3 carbonos porque no
estamos recibiendo estos 6 carbonos de
aquí en vez de eso solo se pueden
producir 6 de estas moléculas de 3
y luego otras seis moléculas de 2
carbonos llamadas fosfórico lato y una
vez más no estoy mostrando todos los
exige nos y no estoy mostrando todos los
fosfatos solo estoy representando los
carbonos y así esto parece ser una gran
pérdida la planta no puede utilizar esos
carbonos pero la evolución nos ha dado
las vías para por lo menos salvar algo
de esta situación pero es una vía muy
intensa
podríamos decir para poder recuperar
parte de esos carbonos y la razón por la
que queremos recuperar algunos de esos
carbonos es porque recuerda al final del
día queremos producir algo de glucosa y
queremos que el ciclo de calvin normal
siga pasando y solo para que tengas una
idea de cómo es la ruta de recuperación
esta molécula de 2 carbonos tiene que
ser convertida agrícola pto luego tiene
que ir a los peroxisomas donde se
convierte en glicina y luego tiene que
ir a la mitocondria y como puedes ver
todo
este proceso tiene que ocurrir solo para
poder salvarlo y convertir esas
moléculas en unas cuantas más de las
moléculas de 3 carbonos y eso es
esencialmente lo que ocurre por aquí
obtenemos tres más de las moléculas de 3
carbonos pero perdemos por la forma en
la que lo he representado aquí 3
moléculas de dióxido de carbono y esa es
una de las razones por las que se llama
foto respiración en la respiración
utilizamos oxígeno y producimos dióxido
de carbono y eso es exactamente lo que
está sucediendo estamos utilizando el
oxígeno y estamos produciendo dióxido de
carbono y así como puedes ver este
mecanismo aparentemente empieza por el
ciclo de calvin pero lo interrumpe o lo
hace menos eficiente y una vez más por
qué sucede esto
bueno podría ser sólo una peculiaridad
biológica que no haya sido seleccionada
en contra con suficiente fuerza
algunas personas creen que en realidad
tiene algunos mecanismos que no están
muy bien comprendidos y que de alguna
manera ayudan a la planta pero es algo
muy interesante que ocurre y como puedes
ver rubisco no es solo una enzima
secundaria en este proceso es
fundamental para el ciclo de calvin y si
observamos materia vegetal en particular
las hojas de las plantas va a
representar aproximadamente 20 por
ciento de la masa proteica de esas hojas
así que es una enzima muy común pero
tiene esta peculiaridad esta
peculiaridad que se lleva a la planta
por el camino de la foto respiración